Sweet, let's do this!
Let's get the show on the road!
MAN: You're going to be
the eyes and the air.
I'll be here on the ground.
[inaudible]
Today's the day!
I believe the only way
to find Eugene's treasure
is to walk in his final steps
to the place where he died.
NARRATOR: And that's just
what these boys are gonna do.
Let's rock and roll!
Woo hoo hoo!
NARRATOR: Now when you
got miles of ground
to cover looking for treasure,
it's always best to get
one of them bird's eye views.
Man, lord, [bleep]
Willie's in the boat.
NARRATOR: And no one
knows that better
than the swamp man himself.
ANDRE: The other day, the boat
drifts away with Willie in it.
NARRATOR: Especially if you're
trying to find something
that means the world to you.
That's it.
Thank God, the boat!
Thank the lord Jesus.
- Willie!
NARRATOR: And just
like the swamp man,
Brandon and Dre are hoping
to find something that could
mean the world to them too.
And high up in
the skies, Brandon
might have found something
peeking out from down below.
He said it's back here
about a half a mile back.
OK, let's [inaudible]
let's go get it.
[inaudible] back.
Right here.
Oh my God.
LANE: What is it?
Lane, I think I know
exactly what this is.
BRANDON: Woo, I'm so pumped!
I'll pull this
thing out of the mud.
LANE: I could tell something
was back here, but I don't know.
Just looks like a
piece of wood to me.
Yeah, but look.
See it?
See the tip, how it's carved?
LANE: Yeah.
This is a dugout.
Easy does it.
LANE: I got you.
- Here, here, grab my--
- I got you.
- Grab my [inaudible].
NARRATOR: Back in
Bunch's day, there
weren't no jet boats or yachts.
In these parts, if he
wanted to get around fast,
you built yourself a dugout--
a small, lightweight canoe
dug right out of a tree.
Swing it closer.
I'm a pull it up on the boat.
NARRATOR: It wasn't fancy, but
for a train robber on the run,
it more than did the trick.
This is the same bayous
that Eugene Bunch used.
The swamp is right over there.
The hollows are not far.
This is the exact kind of boat.
LANE: This is exactly
what you need.
Exactly.
LANE: Get out.
I'm telling you.
NARRATOR: Just like
Shelby Dunn when he
found that three ton anchor--
If it wasn't for
you, we wouldn't
have this here for the
general public to look at.
NARRATOR: --Brandon and
Dre might have uncovered
a genuine piece of
Louisiana history
and a slice of their
swamp heritage.
We're on it.
Look at this thing!
We're this close to
finding Eugene's treasure.
This is the spot.
The treasure's got to be close.